For someone who is estrogen receptor positive, taking an asterisk song, what supplements might help come back joining me?
Even though it is prescribed daily, I wonder about taking a lower dose combined with a supplement.
Yeah, the problem with doing a
estrogen blocker is that you do get symptoms.
Because people think, oh, my hormones are only for certain functions of my body.
They don't realize that your hormones really help with this overall systemic balance of health in your body.
And when you decrease estrogens dramatically in a relatively short period of time, you can end up with all sorts of weird symptoms.
And joint pain, hand pain, and skin issues and all sorts of things go along with it.
Trying to deal with it from a comorbidity standpoint can be helpful.
One thing that can be helpful is the taking more increase in your flavonoids, which would be the curcumin-green t-extract,
resveratrol, stinging nettles, corsets, and that can help with pain, that can help with
with us peripheral inflammation that can go along with decreasing estrogens.
Certainly, you can talk to your doctor about decreasing your dosage.
Remember, whatever they're dosing you on these things, they're giving you just the standard dosage that comes along with their electronic mercury manual.
They're not really treating you as an individual.
You have to ask for it.
So ask that, hey, I want to go down on my dosage and see if it works the same way if it's still decreasing my estrogens.
And if they push back at that and they say, well, no, we have to use this dosage because this is what's really going to work.
Then say, then say, okay, I want you to measure it then.
I want you to measure my estrogen.
Do a blunt test, measure your estrogen levels.
And if it's down in the pits like they want it to be, then let's go a lower dose and let's measure it again and see if it's still down in the pits.
You got to push for the care that you want.
You know, you have to take charge of your care like that.
So that's what I would suggest.
I think you're right on the right track.
Whoever asks this question, you ask questions on of your prescribed doctor and see if you can get a different dosage.
I think that's good.
Good.